the US economy taking another hit in the
wake of the corona virus pandemic with
700 1000 jobs lost last month an
unemployment surging to 4.4 percent and
as leaders of both sides of the aisle
begin work on the next phase of a
stimulus package how soon can we see
more relief well here to join us to talk
about it is House Minority Whip Steve
Scalise good morning congressman how are
you doing well good morning good to be
with you let's talk about this we are
the jobs report terrible it's gonna get
even worse you've got the phase three
out there how do you assess where we
stand as we hit this weekend a lot of
work has been put in this last week in
the making phase three work successfully
for those companies and those families
that are struggling and you saw record
numbers near 10 million unemployed just
in the last two weeks and you know look
we're seeing every business trying to
figure out how they're gonna hold on to
their business and their workers the
bill we passed last week was designed to
help bring people back off the
unemployment rolls and hold on to the
workers that you have while they can get
paid under that bill and it would be a
forgivable loan you saw yesterday the
program just went online and tremendous
success in that program we've seen a lot
of interest just in the last week I've
had calls with every kind of small
business group and mediums and large
sized business group that are trying to
figure out how to make it work for
themselves Treasury secretary minuchin
has been working overtime on behalf of
President Trump who really president
Trump was the one who said I want to
make sure the money gets in the hands of
people and of businesses that we can
hopefully have hold on through all of
this so that we can have an economy to
come back to and yesterday the program
came off to a really successful start
there's a lot of work to be done but
Treasury was even working last night to
revise some of the rules to make sure
that there's clarity so people know how
it works for them so that they can apply
for and get these loans and hold on to
their jobs and their small businesses
families can hold on to their homes yeah
representative in these unique times
price tags and pretty much gone out the
window so a lot of people look at two
trillion and they say it's a huge number
for phase three yet there's already talk
on Capitol Hill from leadership on both
sides of the aisle about a potential
phase for do you support that what would
be in it right now my focus has been on
making phase three work there's so many
aspects of phase three for families that
gives a lot of relief I mean release for
individuals you can get loan forbearance
for example where you can go to your
bank and ask them for an extension of
maybe three months at the end of your
notes so that the next three months you
don't have to pay your house note or
your business note that's in the bill
the ability again to get these small
business loans medium and large sized
companies companies over 500 everywhere
from the biggest companies in the world
you've heard about the airline industry
all of the kind of companies that are
struggling right now have an ability to
go and get relief so that they can hold
on through this crisis and then when we
come out of this hopefully in the weeks
ahead that those jobs are still there
our economy has is something we can come
back to the focus needs to be on making
that bill work and a lot of energy by
the way has been focused on making a
great totally agree what then get to the
next step when you see leaders talking
about another phase people start to say
exactly what you said wait wait we just
passed phase three people are figuring
out how to how to access it what's this
talk about another one I mean would you
support do you think there might be a
need for a fourth phase well again when
you look at what is in this third bill
and by the way there were two other
bills that were passed prior to that so
you have somewhere near three trillion
dollars of taxpayer money that's out
there right now working for families and
families are just working through the
details themselves to see how it's going
to work like treasurer 'man secretary
minuchin said yesterday maybe another
two weeks that IRS component where
people are gonna get $1200 per person
coming through their IRS automatic
deposit those kind of things haven't
even happened yet that was in the third
bill so let's make all the focus on
getting that money into the pockets of
families so that they can get through
these next few weeks
clearly there's gonna be talking about
what happens next in Congress but
especially what what we can do to get
the economy back open again and I know
President Trump is focused on that every
day while he's focused on the health and
safety of the American families first
before we let you go we have to get your
opinion on this the White House Task
Force is obviously very carefully mock
air for
monitoring the cases in Louisiana as
they spiked and continued to spike
president Trump saying that medical
supplies will arrive in New Orleans
today tell us about that state and
what's happening there yeah that's
something we've been working with the
president all the way down through FEMA
talked to the FEMA administrator at the
beginning of this week and they assured
us they were going to get more PPE and
ventilators down to New Orleans and they
have they've gotten it through the
state's
Office of Emergency Preparedness I've
been working with our governor John bel
Edwards on that too and so everybody is
working together I talked to the head of
one of the hospitals again last night
Warner Thomas who the president
mentioned who's been working really hard
just like all the other hospitals in the
region people have been stepping up to
the challenge our hospital workers are
stepping up to the challenge we wanted
to make sure we got them more protective
equipment the PPE that you hear is in
such demand we were able to get over
110,000 more PPEs for those workers that
are that are really the brave frontline
workers taking care of people so
everybody's pulling together you know
it's horrible that the tragedies that
you see are real but people are doing a
better job of sheltering at home of
washing their hands in in social
distancing because they realize they
every matter of American can play a part
in stopping the spread of this disease
well and you're in a hot spot there
congressman so we'll be thinking about
you and all the people down there in
Louisiana thank you sir thank you we're
all sticking together god bless you and
stay safe